execute order 66.
palpatine's execution of order 66 killed
off almost every jedi from the star wars
prequels but there are still a few that
are expected to appear in the obi-wan
kenobi series streaming on disney plus
may 27th from video game characters to
jedi we thought were dead there are
several characters that can make a
pretty good case for returning in the
series now let's get started with the
return of one of the most unexpected
jedi of all mace windu
back in 2005 we saw mace windu fall to
his death after being disarmed literally
and hit by force lightning out a window
or so we thought we've seen plenty of
jedi survive limbs being severed being
hit by force lightning and falling from
great heights so it's not out of the
question that mace windu could have
survived the whole ordeal in revenge of
the sith i mean if darth maul can
survive this
then mace probably could have made it
out alive too samuel l jackson even went
so far as to say in my mind i'm not dead
jedi can fall from incredibly high
distances and not die and george lucas
apparently had nothing against windu
surviving so in all likelihood he could
be alive and make an appearance in the
obi-wan kenobi series
up next is the fan favorite character
calcus who made his debut appearance in
the video game jedi fallen order this
game takes place five years before the
obi-wan series will take place so it
makes sense for cow to appear as he
attempts to revive the jedi order
cameron monahan voiced cal and gave the
character his likeness so monahan would
be the perfect choice to reprise the
role for the first time in live action
kestus likely would have grown stronger
in the years following the video game
and could have found other jedi to begin
rebuilding the order so we may get to
see more than one jedi in his company if
he does appear this is getting out of
hand
now there are two of them
one of the most exciting characters
rumored to appear is qui-gon jinn after
his death in the phantom menace qui-gon
learned the path to immortality
according to yoda and is able to
reappear in the form of a force ghost we
actually saw him use this ability in the
clone wars tv series so we know it's
quite possible it's likely that obi-wan
would feel the need to reach out to his
old master during his exile on tatooine
so liam neeson's beloved character very
well could make an appearance in the
show as a ghost
who you gonna call
someone else
up next is the former jedi anakin
skywalker who's confirmed to be in the
series as darth vader we've seen
anakin's story on the big screen from
the time he put on the suit up to around
the time the death star was built but we
have a huge piece of his story missing
between these times and it's expected
that hayden christensen will finally get
to have a fiery rematch with his old
master obi-wan i also expect to see some
sort of flashbacks likely to obi-wan and
anakin's adventures during the clone
wars i mean if they're bringing back
hayden christensen for the role i think
it's pretty likely we'll get to see
anakin with a face that isn't cooked
medium rare yet
the next group confirmed to appear in
the series are the inquisitors who we've
seen before in video games such as jedi
fallen order and an animated tv series
such as star wars rebels the inquisitors
are typically former jedi who joined the
sith and now hunt jedi in the years
following order 66. so in a way these
inquisitors are jedi for the most part
and it's likely that they'll end up
finding other jedi who may appear in the
series kumiyonyanjani is confirmed to be
in this series and based on his robes we
saw in the series trailer it's rumored
that he may be a jedi on the run from
the inquisitors with a pretty
significant role in the plot of the
series
the next jedi expected to appear is
kanan jairus who survived order 66 after
this jairus became a smuggler in the
animated series rebels and renounced his
jedi ways seeing him in live action is
something fans have asked for ever since
the possibility presented itself when
his ship the ghost appeared in rogue one
and the rise of skywalker he also
appeared in both the seventh season of
the clone wars and the bad batch as the
young caleb doom and we heard his
disembodied voice in the rise of
skywalker so his appearance in the
kenobi series is definitely not out of
the question 100 organic
one character that's expected to appear
who isn't really a jedi is ahsoka tano
ahsoka was originally a member of the
jedi order as a padawan to anakin
skywalker but after being framed for a
crime she didn't commit during the
animated clone wars series she left the
order never to return since then she's
made appearances in star wars rebels the
mandalorian the book of boba fett and
she's set to get her own tv series
probably sometime in 2022 i think it's
very likely we'll get to see her in the
series because we've already seen her in
live action after animation premiere in
the clone wars and it would help to set
the stage for her solo series later this
year also obi-wan and ahsoka both share
the pain of losing anakin to the dark
side so it would be nice to see them
have a heart to heart about their lost
friend before potentially facing him
together let's finish this the way we
started
together
up next is luminara unduli a jedi master
we got to know in the clone wars series
we know unduly survived order 66 but was
later executed by the empire and used
his bait during star wars rebels it
isn't known when exactly the empire
executed her so she could very well
appear in obi-wan kenobi her own padawan
turned against the jedi order when she
bombed the jedi temple and framed ahsoka
tano and this is something kenobi can
more than relate to after the downfall
of his own padawan so having them
interact might add some comfort to the
aging jedi master
move along
[Music]
the last and maybe one of the most
unexpected jedi to potentially appear is
master yoda the wise jedi master
survived order 66 when he sensed his
clone troopers were about to turn on him
and took them out before they could
react after battling and losing to darth
sidious yoda went into hiding in the
dagobah system until luke skywalker
arrived seeking training jedi were
stretched very thin across the galaxy at
this time so it would make sense that
kenobi and yoda would find some way to
stay in contact with one another even if
it's just a cameo it would be great to
see the legendary master return once
again
while none of these characters are
officially confirmed to appear in the
series i think it's more than likely
that we'll get to see a few of them
later this month when the kenobi series
is released but now it's over to you
which jedi do you think will appear in
the series drop your answers in the
comment section below also check out the
video on your screen for some more
content don't forget to like and
subscribe and thanks for watching rocket
riley
[Music]